you created Nerdist Empire okay you
probably think I'm guessing I'm guessing
that Chris Hardwick thinks that he is
the king of comic-con but I want to tell
you something okay I hate to take the
starch out of your shorts but when it
comes to comic books when it comes to
superhero movies yeah when it comes to
sci-fi and fantasy characters and all
things nerd there's no bigger expert in
the world than I so you're a hundred
percent confident that you can back that
up
I can back that up well then you should
have no problem passing this just
invented comic-con citizenship tests
right here let's do it all right all
right sir please
all right here we go beginning ready go
Wolverines claws are made of what metal
adamantium good what does the acronym
shield stand for stands for strategic
homeland intervention enforcement and
logistics division excellent very well
so far who's the greatest warrior in
house Stark Tony good
and before who wields a purple
lightsaber my dog when he gets too
excited the five who is your favorite
character on Game of Thrones whoever is
just about to get killed just Jackson
number six look was Daredevils greatest
enemy on the even floors that's very
true seven
how does Bruce Banner get ready for sex
he makes his penis angry yes he does and
you wouldn't want to see it when it's
all right
eight if Caitlyn Jenner was a superhero
what team would she be on the x-men yes
what was the right answer number nine
who shot first Han or Greedo neither it
was a Java on the grassy knoll all right
number 10 who was the hero in the porn
version of The Hobbit dildo shagging
that's correct
[Applause]
411 how would you eat on a woman get
pregnant the first time you cannot
alright it's actually true number 12
what is Aquaman's superpower please
rephrase the question
what is Aquaman's power again please
rephrase the question
let's Aquaman do talk to fish yeah very
well so far
got a good run next question
cosplay is not drinks with Bill Cosby
alright
that is a 100% true statement number 14
I'm going to name a fictional character
or team and you have to tell me their
famous battle cry first one Thundercats
Thundercats ho good he-man by the power
of Grayskull Ghost Rider the Justice
League
good luck Superman we'll just wait for
you here next question next question and
this is this is a head scratcher what
would you do if Seth Green suddenly
attacked you with a toy lightsaber well
he's not on the show tonight so I don't
think that's an issue that I'm gonna
have to deal with it anyway Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
that's true the correct answer was
murdering Seth Green
hey thanks for watching be sure to click
subscribe to see even more great Conan
clips you may now return to your pirated
movies and creepy Japanese pornography